would you do me a favor and make the
announcement you you have one more job
you're ready to announce is this true
listen listen to this I'm gonna be a
daily talk show host yeah yeah I'm
because you know I've got a way talking
but no I'm everyday starting in 2020
i'ma have my own show a syndicated talk
show what time will it air around like
11:00 okay I'll do my radio show go
right into my day it's just a result of
filling in for Wendy Williams it is it
is a result so what happened when I left
a gteen I wanted to elevate so I was
like I'm gonna develop a talk show
specifically I was thinking late night
so we made the huge announcement I did
my deal at Fox and then once I filled in
for Wendy I was like oh this is it was
some magic going on like this audience
right you got a lot of good reviews yeah
there was vibing with me so I was like I
let's put the late-night on halls just
for a second and let's develop a daily
talk show know what kind of time you
need listen to me
you're losing you're losing you know you
can't do it something's gonna break that
I I don't
it broke already enough how do you
figure this is gonna work five to ten
you're gonna do the radio show I did 10
days you there live yeah okay cuz
especially if I start from the East
Coast and you know I can syndicate and
be all over so you're thinking of moving
back to the East Coast I want to do a
show in New York I mean I haven't made
the decision you wanted the daytime show
New York but you're gonna have the
morning show on in LA the morning so
don't do it on everywhere oh the morning
show we're gonna say new I'm gonna be
the next Howard Stern I'm trying to be
the king of coffee if you become the
next Howard Stern you're gonna drop all
these products I can barely function